[موسيقى]
حياكم الله في اول شهاده للرئيس السوداني
المعزول عمر البشير امام القضاء السوداني
منذ سقوط نظامه اعترف البشير امام المحكمه
بانه يتحمل مسؤوليه انقلاب 30 مليون عام
1989 قائلا اعلم ان الاعتراف سيد الادله
مشيرا الى انه لم يكن لاي عضو في مجلس
قياده الثوره اي دور في احداث الثلاثين
مليون مضيفا ان قضيه الانقلاب هي قضيه
تونسيه كما كشف البشيرعدم تورط قاده مجلس
الانقاذ في الانقلاب ولم يكن لهم دور في
التخطيط او التنفيذ للانقلاب وان التحرك
لم يكن بمشاركه اي شخصيه مدنيه
لكن عايز ازمه حقيقه مولانا
انه كله اخواننا اعضاء مجلس الثوره
الموجودين هنا
في هذه القاعه
ما كان عندهم اي دور
في التخطيط او التنفيذ
وانما تم اختياره كوكب من غير الضباط
القوات المسلحه عشان يمثل الوحدات وتمسير
بعض الجهال واؤكد ايضا
انه ما في اي مدينه دخل معنا
عامل عسكري بحث
انا باقول من اهم
تدخل القوات المسلحه
هو عكس
الاداره السياسيه
في اداره الشان العامه
واخر فكره قبل الغاز نسيت الثمانين ل 30
يوم 89
تشكلت خمسه حكومات
برئاسه
الامام الصادق المهدي رحمه الله
نعمه الله جبريل المحلل العسكري ومن
الخرطومي ايضا ينضم الينا عروه الصادق
القياديه في حزب الامه القومي اهلا بكم
قبل ان نبدا الحوار كيف دافع محامي البشير
عنه هو كيف انتقده المناهضون في السودان
وقع خارج القياده العامه
قال له انا بتحمل
كل المسؤوليه
عما تم تم في 30 يونيو
ومن الواضح جدا انه ازعج كثيرا جدا من
القوه السياسيه ولذلك الان بدات الحمله
كما يقولون بالكاونتر يعني الان هذه
الحمله ابتداء من هذه المقابله واصوات
المعارضه لها الان همم هذه الاصوات اضطربت
جدا لان الرئيس ظاهر كما قلتم لكاريسما
قويه وبلشخصيه ثابته وبثقه في النفس وبثقه
فيما فعل واقر تم واقر تماما
[موسيقى]
اذا اعود الى ضيوفي اللواء نعمه الله
جبريل المحلل العسكريه ومن الخرطوم ايضا
عروه الصادق القيادي في حزب الامه القومي
اهلا بكما يعني ظهور البشير البعض يراها
كانه
ظهر بطلا في هذه المحاكمه بينما يراه
الاخرون انها طريق للعوده بعد اخراج
الاخوان يريد ان يعود الى الشارع عن
طريقهم سيد جبريل كيف تقرا ذلك
بسم الله والحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه حسين
وشكرا جزيلا التحيه للشعب السوداني
والتحيه لضيفكم الكريم انا افتكر قراءتي
لهذا هو حيه كان مرافعه عاليه القيمه
عاليه
المضامين ااا بفتكر انه اظهرت يعني قوه
وشخصيه وكاريزما الرئيس السابق عمر البشير
انا بالنسبه لي همم هذه المرافعه همم من
منظور همم ازمه السودان نحنا ازمه السودان
تتلخص في ثلاثه اشياء ازمه قياده
وازمه تفكير استراتيجي
وازمه سلوك
انا مبتكر انه الرئيس عمر البشير الان
ارسل رساله واضحه بين وان هو قائد
بغض النظر عن ما فعل وما لا افعل
والاعتراف هو زي ما قال الاعتراف سيد
الادله
وبالتالي القائد معني باي عمل يقوم به
المرئيس السيسي
وانا بفتكر دي فيها نعم منتهى يعني
الشجاعه
الاحساس
الكاريزما القياديه
يعني توافق على على ما يتفضل في سيد جبريل
بما ان هناك كاريزما هناك قوه شخصيه الرجل
القيادي وانا اختلفت معه
التحيه لك ولضيوف ضيفك الكريم والاستاد
المشاهدين اخي العزيز هذه المسرحيه لا
ظلنا نواصل مشاهده فصولها العبثيه فلا زال
يؤكد البشير تماما انه دميه تحرك باحابيل
الاخوان في السودان
وتلعب في ملعب
عرائس على نسمه ومرء الجميع
ببساطه لان التنظيم والغ في دماء الشعب
السوداني الذين
اهدر الدمائهم جراء هذا الانقلاب ملايين
من القتلى ملايين من النازحين واللاجين
سببهم والجرم الاساسي ارتكبه هذا النظام
الذي اتى به الاخوان لذلك البشير همم اريد
له ان يبرئ الاخوان ويبرئ ساحتهم لان هذه
الادانه للاخوان عبر هذه المحاكمه يمكن ان
تهيئهم كل قوائم ان يكونوا جماعه ارهابيه
ويمنع ويحضر كما هم هو الان في خلال
الفتره الانتقاليه ويصنف هذا التصنيف هذا
التصنيف البشير اكد تماما انه لا زال
بعافيته كل ادعاءات المطل وتسويف
المحاكمات بحجه انه مريض هذه ثبت بطلانها
وظهر بعافيته الرجل الرجل
يتحمل مسؤوليه في الانقلاب سواه وبالتالي
من جاء بهم من المدنيين جاء بهم بعد
الانقلاب على يبرئهم ذلك وان كانوا معه في
السجن الان
البشير جاء به جاء به من وين حاميه ميم
قبيل الانقلاب جاء به ولم ياتي ولم يكن
يعلم انه على صله او بمواعيد التنفيذ
مواعيد التنفيذ والتخطيط له خطط لها بليل
من قبل قياده التنظيم ومجلس الشورى الذي
كان يراسه وقتئذ بروفيسير الطيب زين
العابدين له الرحمه وهو من من رفضوا
الانقلاب ضمن اثنين اخرين قالوا باننا نحن
من خططنا واتينا بالبشير والشيخ حسن عبد
الله الترابي في افادته شهاده على العصر
التي نقلتها الجزيره الشهيده بذلك وغيرهم
كثر من الاحياء والاموات شهاداتهم مستوره
ومنشوره ما قاله البشير هو كذب محض محض
كذب وادعاءات كذوبه وبطوله لن يطى لها
لانه لن يمضي في الثبات على هذه الافاده
لانها تترتب عليها جرائم كبيره جدا
ومحاكمه اللواء نعمه الله جبريل كيف ترى
ذلك هل توافق فيه
شكرا لضيفك الكريم وانا بفتكر حتى ولو كان
المرحوم الشيخ حسن الترابي ادلى ب ب ب
بيانات وحتى لو البشير الان قال ما شارك
معي اي مدني دا اول حاجه يعني يعني ده اول
حاجه اتهام
وتقليل لهؤلاء المدنيين الذين لا يدركون
اي شيء
سواء عن خططه ولا عمله هو في النهايه تحمل
المسؤوليه وهذه القياده التي لا يعلم
المدنيون
وبفتكر انه رسل رساله خطيره جدا للاحزاب
ان هؤلاء الاحزاب لا خير فيهم وبالتالي
انا مبتكر انه تحمل المسؤوليه حتى ما ما
احيانا انت بتشيل القضيه بدون ما يكون
يعني ما يكون انت كتبت جريمه احيانا نحن
عندنا في القضاء اشياء كثيره جدا ناس
بيشيلوا المسؤوليه مسئوليه البشير ان
يعترف بانه د افعله ما شئتم كل ما جرى في
الانقاذ هو يتحمل مسؤوليته كامله
افمن الحركه الاسلاميه
ماذا فعلت من الحركه الاسلاميه والحركه
الاسلاميه ديل تقدم النظر عنه انا كنت
معانا ولا ما بعرفهم لكن يا اخواننا
الحركه الاسلاميه ده جسمي في السودان لن
يلقى بفكره وبالتالي هذا الرعب من انه
الحركه الاسلاميه والحركه الاسلاميه ماذا
فعل احنا عايزينهم على الارض
اعملوا انتخابات عشان نشوف الحركه
الاسلاميه ديت وانا هذه الفوبيا من
الاسلاميه
كما يقول همم سيد جبريل يعني او اشوفك
مبتسم ما معنى هذه الابتسامه
هو يعلم ان الحركه الاسلاميه لو قدر لها
العوده
لك وهذا ذئبها هذه الحركه الاسلاميه لو
كانت تقتنع بالانتخابات لا منقلبت على
حكومه هي ضمن همم مجلسها الوزاري الحركه
الاسلاميه يا اخي ما صلت به جنود
السودانيين لا يمكن لاي نظام قادم ان
يستوعبهم بذات الفكر وكل قيادات الحركه
الاسلاميه المرجعيه المرجعيه ولا اظن ضيفه
منهم كلهم راجعوا قالوا يجب ان يراجع منهج
يجب ان يراجع القياده يجب ان يراجع
البرنامج لاننا ارتكبنا فضائح في حق الشعب
السوداني وكان شيخهم يقول نستغفر الله على
ما فعلناها في الشعب السوداني هذه كلها لن
تؤهلهم للعوده اما محاوله تمريراتهم قد
بينت لك انهم لا يريدون ان يدانوا قانوني
الرساله الى الاحزاب الى الى كل الاحزاب
بان القياده ليست ليست فقط بالشعارات او
ما يدار حاليا
يا سيدي البشير انقلب على حكومه كان
مديونيتها مدينتها مليارات الدولارات
ونموها سالب 12 حينما استلم الحكم كان
معدلا النمو موجب 12 معدل نمو في ثلاث
سنوات 24 حققت الحكومه اتفاقيه سلام كان
مقررا لها ان توقع في ديسمبر
1989 انقض عليها قبيل الانقلاب قال البشير
بانه استلم نظام مهترئا وضالا يكذب في
المحكمه وجد نظام منفتح فاغلقه بعقوبات
دوليه وادرج السودان ضمن قوائم الدول
الراعي الارهاب اي فشل يتحدث عنه البشير
الاحزاب كانت تغير حكومتها بالتداول
السلمي للسلطه ولكنهم اتخذوا من البندقيه
والدبابه وسيله للصعود الى السلطه
يعني عوده الاسلاميه كما يقول ضيفي لن
تاتي الا عن طريق الدماء بالاضافه الى انه
بالدبابه والبندقيه همم هو الحكم
انا حقيقه ماذا القى نفسي ادافع عن الحركه
الاسلاميه والاسلاميه
وانا لست منهم ولكن هذه الحركه الاسلاميه
بكل هذه الدماء جاء شخص جاء
تبن هذه القضيه حاكموه على
الاعتراف سيد الاضلا الان
حتى يخرج الاخوان من
المحاكمه وبالتالي اذا عادوا الى ساحه
سياسيه قد يعودون به
طيب هذه هي السياسه والمحاكمه سياسيه ماذا
تنتظرون منه
انا ما معهم لكن يا اخواننا انت اعرف عدوك
انت العمده عندكم
انا بتكلم عن القوات المسلحه لما بتكلم عن
القوات المسلحه
كنت عارف الوضع الوضع الان انتم تمام على
على على على تدمير القوات المسلحه وعلى
تفكيك القوات المسلحه وهذا لم يحصل طيب
باختصار لانه انتهى وقتي
نعم
يا سيدي يا سيدي العزيز مو يوم التي يتباك
عنها كانت في حكم السودان ميه التي تتباكى
عنها سقطت في ايدي قوه متمرده على السلطه
المركزيه كانت في حضن السودان وكان
بالامكان فقط
ابدا الجيش السوداني عصي على التفكيك وعصي
على انه
يدين ضمن قوه كما فعل الحركه الاسلاميه
يجب ان ينفك هذا الجيش من رفقه الحركه
الاسلاميه التي استعبدته لمده 30 عام
وادخلت فيه ما ادخلت من ايدولوجين هذه
العناصر الايديولوجيه الفاسده يجب ان تخرج
من الجيش في الجيش السوداني فيه ضباط
مؤهلون اطفال شرفاء قادرين على الزوج
وحمايه هذا الوطن ولكن يريدون ان يمتطوا
ظهر الجيش ياتوا به كما فعل البشير في 89
عبره انقلاب الجبهه الاسلاميه ساعه اللواء
كلمه اخيره لك حق الرد باختصار اذا تكرمت
الكلمه الاخيره اقول انه عمر البشير اثبت
قياده وكرزما مفقوده حتى الان نحن لم نعرف
قادتكم
الان عمر البشير اذا عبر الاسلاميين وما
براهم الاسلاميه
انقلها
الاسلاميين انا ما معونه بينكم ثم القوات
المسلحه التي تتحدث عنها
تضعون يدكم ومعاكم ناس كانوا هدموا القوات
حاربوا قوات المسلحه شكرا
جزيلا سعاده اللواء نعمه الله جبريل
المحلل العسكري من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
وايضا الشكر موصول لعروه الصادق القيادي
في حزب الامه شكرا جزيلا لكما